from the moment you walk into our front
door and you see the teak and Holly
floors the big pink smiling whale you
just know that you arrived at Vineyard
Vines Shep and I are real guys we're
brothers
we took eight thousand dollar credit
card cash advance quit our jobs made
some pies and kept reinvesting our own
money into the business and had turned
it into something really special we are
not a fashion brand we're a lifestyle
brand and that's been really really
helpful when we charted the course of
designing this office hey guys what's
going on hey mags how are you AG what we
went to look for a new office we had a
few criteria we wanted to be on the
water we wanted to be in our own
building and we wanted it to convey kind
of like being at home that's not the
look about this we wanted the whole
building to sort of recover and so
you'll see our conference tables weren't
bought from an office furniture place we
actually built them in the shape of
votes and every single floor has their
own lounge and they're modeled after
their favorite places so we've got the
Florida Keys and one we've got the
vineyard boathouse and another we've got
the Bahamas and this this room off of
our office is kind of like a ship's room
so this here is our office we spend our
days Shep and I've been sharing an
office for a little over 17 years that
whale right there was hand-carved by our
father and if you look at this picture
here this is the house that we grew up
in and there's the whale above the front
door so our whole life we sort of had a
whale over the threshold and that really
inspired us in our brand we love all
these porthole tables that we've got a
bunch of and this was a coffee table
that was in our parents house and we
don't even have a conference table in
our office when you walk into this place
hopefully it's going to feel as as close
to home in a in an office environment